-Welcome back to the show.
Thank you for playing
"What's Behind Me?"
-That was so much fun.
-I appreciate that.
It's the best.
-That was bizarre.
-It is bizarre.
It's always great to see you.
First of all,
congratulations on the
Independent Spirit Award
nomination.
This is a giant.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Just now. Recently.
-Yeah.
-That's major.
-Thank you.
Actually -- And I want to say
congratulations
to Marin Ireland,
one of my co-stars in "Eileen,"
and our director,
William Oldroyd,
because they got nominated, too.
-They got nominated, as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-I know the film
was shot in New Jersey.
-Yes.
-And you are from New Jersey.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You are a Jersey girl.
-Hello, hello. My queens.
I have some facts that I don't
know if they're real or fake
that I got off the Internet
about you growing up,
and I just wanted to ask you
and maybe see --
-About me growing up
in New Jersey?
-Yes. In New Jersey. Yes.
-Oh, my God!
-And see if any of these
are real or true --
-Oh, this is terrifying.
-No. These are
all kind of interesting.
Okay.
-They're all good.
-Okay.
-Here's one.
"Anne Hathaway once won a
free-throw shooting contest."
-[ Laughs ]
-Is this a true story?
-No. I mean, yes,
but I didn't win.
-Okay.
-So, it was
the Knights of Columbus...
-Yes! The Knights of
Columbus, yeah.
-...sponsored
a free-throw competition
when I was 10, maybe.
And I won the first round.
-You did?
-But then I choked
when we got to states,
and so I did not win,
but I won a little bit.
-Were you athletic?
Are you athletic?
-I'm okay. I'm okay.
I -- When I was growing up,
I was really inconsistent.
Like, I would, like,
have days where I was fire,
and then I would have days
where people would be like,
"Is it the same human?"
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
"She doesn't know
what she's doing at all."
How about this?
When you were 9,
you won your town's talent show.
-No. No. No, no, no.
It -- Well, first of all, it was
a Kiwanis Club talent show.
Clearly, we were big into clubs
growing up.
-Yeah. Wow. So Knights of
Columbus and Kiwanis Club.
-Kiwanis Club. And they had --
It wasn't for my town.
It was -- I don't know how --
what part of
New Jersey it was focusing on.
And I didn't win,
but I did come in third.
-You didn't?
What was your talent?
-I don't know that you
would call it that,
but I sang a song called
"Johnny One Note,"
which is from --
which is a Judy Garland song.
-"Johnny One Note"?
-"Johnny One Note."
But it was, like, crazy,
because the girl who won
was this classically
trained pianist,
and she played this unbelievably
difficult sonata.
And then I went up there,
like, 9-year-old me,
and the downbeat hit
and the mic came up
and my left -- I remember this.
Right hand holding the mic.
Left hand just went...
And I stayed like that
the entire song.
But -- literally.
And it's a 3-1/2-minute song.
And just this. Just this.
So, yeah.
But I came in third.
-That's pretty good.
It's wild. Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much. Thank you.
-Did you have
a costume for this?
-I did. Oh my God, yes.
I -- My mom
went to a thrift store,
and she got me
this little white bolero jacket.
A bolero jacket is one
that comes to here with this,
like, tiny, little collar.
And then, guys,
she took red and black felt
and cut music notes...
-Come on.
-...and glued them on and then
glued glitter on top of that.
-That's what I'm talking about
Mom. Come on!
-Mom. Absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then I wore the whole thing
on top. a shiny unitard.
-Yeah, shiny unitard.
And only third place?
Come on! That's first place.
-Only third place.
-In our hearts.
-[ Laughs ]
-I want to talk about "Eileen."
By the way, it's phenomenal.
-Thank you for watching it.
-Oh, I loved it.
-I love that you loved it.
I just -- I love it, too.
-Oh, it was great.
Also, you know what I love, too?
The -- Who plays Eileen.
Who is...
-Thomasin McKenzie.
She's incredible.
-I don't know her.
-Right?
-She's fantastic.
-I know her very well now.
-Yeah. Now, yeah, sure.
-No, she's a joy.
And, like, we -- Like, this film
was super-duper intense, and --
-Oh, I didn't know
where it was going at all.
-I know. I know.
-Set in the '60s.
-She's amazing.
She's a young actress.
She was in "Jojo Rabbit."
She was in "Old."
She's been in so many films.
"Power of the Dog."
And --
-You guys are great together.
-She's incredible.
She's got a face like
it's carved from moondust.
She's so beautiful.
-Also, who directed this?
-William Oldroyd.
William Oldroyd.
And he directed
Florence Pugh's debut film,
which was called "Lady Macbeth."
-It's just so beautiful
to look at.
And the score is great,
by the way.
-Yes, Richard Reed Parry
from "Arcade Fire."
-No way!
-Yes.
-Alright, this is all stuff
I didn't know, but I loved it.
And I go, "Okay, I kind of
understand where this is going,"
and then I was way off.
-Yeah.
-I did not know
where this was going.
-No.
-That last scene?
-Shh.
-No.
Well, you'll see.
I won't say anything.
-I hope you go to see it.
-Yes.
-I really hope you
go to see it, because --
-How do we describe the film?
'60s.
-It's a Christmas love story.
[ Laughs ]
-It is not. It is not
a Christmas love story.
-It's a Christmas love story,
Jimmy.
-No, that's not
how I would describe it.
-Every day on set, we would
be doing something so twisted,
and then Will would just go,
"It's a Christmas love story."
-Like, it is weirdly set
in the holidays.
-Yeah. But it is set 1964,
Christmastime,
Massachusetts, in the suburbs,
in one of those towns
with really
pretty picket fences,
but you don't know what's going
on inside anybody's home.
-Yeah.
-And Thomasin McKenzie,
the wonderful girl
who I just -- a young actress
who I just described --
she plays Eileen Dunlop,
who is a 24-year-old young woman
who works as a secretary
in a boys prison.
-Yeah.
-And her life kind of seems like
it's over before it's begun.
And then...enter me.
-Enter you, yes.
Of course. Yes.
-And I play
Dr. Rebecca St. John,
who is a psychologist, and I've
come to the boys prison
and I have some ideas of my own.
-Yes. What a tricky role.
And well-deserved
on that nomination.
-Thank you so much.
-I want to talk about --
You have a scream
that is unbelievable.
-Yes, I do.
-Yeah.
-You're showing the scream clip.
-Well, I'm going
to show the clip,
but, also, this --
IndieWire said that,
"This is the year of
Anne Hathaway's primal scream,"
because you --
-So, I can explain.
I did a film
that came out earlier this year
in which I play a psychologist.
I'm worried about
getting typecast.
-Yeah, typecast.
-And she has a nervous breakdown
and she screams
really loud in it.
And then, in this film,
there's a scream in it, as well.
So, it's so, so weird
that you have two films
that come out back-to-back
where you play psychologists
who scream.
-Do you have -- I don't know
if I've ever heard you scream.
I did in this film.
-Yeah.
-But, I mean, wow!
Are you used to --
Did you train to primal-scream?
-To primal-scream?
-It is a primal scream.
-I've been preparing
my whole life, Jimmy,
to do a primal scream.
-I mean, it comes from your gut.
You're like, "Aaah!"
I mean, it's like, wow!
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Does it feel good
to scream like that?
-It feels fabulous.
It feels amazing, yeah.
I just -- Yeah, I think --
Have you ever done it?
-Uh, no. I think I bottled up
my primal scream.
-Would you like to?
-I would -- I'd love to scream.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I have a question.
Has everybody
here made it through 2023?
Did everybody make it
through 2022 before that,
2021 before that,
and 2020 before that?
-Yeah.
-We're gonna primal-scream.
Let's go. Come on.
-Oh, we're all going to do it?
-We're all gonna do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stand up.
-Oh, here we go.
-Stand up. Hi.
Taking control of the show.
I love it.
-I'm excited to
scream with you today.
So excited to stream with you.
Is it okay that I
took control of the show?
-I love that you took
control of my show, yes.
Are you guys ready
to primal-scream?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, what is the tip?
What's a tips?
-There is no trick.
Just let it out, guys.
-Really?
-Okay? Ready?
-Primal scream. Here we go.
Here's to a great 2024.
[ All screaming ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh. Wow! Let's go!
-Whoo!
-It feels great!
It feels great!
I want to show a clip.
Here's Anne Hathaway
in "Eileen."
Take a look at this.
-You live here alone?
-No. Oh, uh, sure.
I, uh -- No,
I can't have roommates.
I, um -- I like my own space,
I still like to have fun,
and, uh, I can make
a lot of noise
and, um, I can make a mess,
as you can see.
But, uh, I can play music
as loud as I want to.
I can -- I can scream
[ Laughs ]
[ Screams ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on!
-And now you know how to do it.
-You're so good.
Watch this movie, everybody.
It is fantastic.
"Eileen" is in theaters now.